this video is sponsored by surf shark
the streak continues
wado is amazing and on top of it having
some of the best action sequences so far
it also has one of the craziest
callbacks i've ever seen in a long
running anything
which is sort of auspicious because i'm
now nearing the end of this series for
the time being and
to be honest even saying that out loud
is sort of surreal
five months ago i hadn't read a single
chapter of the superlative master class
in shonen storytelling and now i'm after
arriving on the shores of wano
it's been incredible it's been long but
most importantly
so worthwhile and what's more is today
i'll be surpassing the anime now
obviously there will be no spoilers used
up until i surpass the anime and once i
do there will be a clear warning for
anyone that wishes to dip out thereafter
but
the very fact that i'm able to say that
is nuts to me
we're finally on the home stretch guys
and today we're diving into and
dissecting the second part to this
sprawling tale of shogun
samurai and smiles i'm totally not mark
and these are my first impressions of
thoughts on and review for
the tragic the powerful and the awesome
wanno act two
alrighty so in the last episode i
explored various story structures from
the modern three-act structure
all the way to the classical five-act
structure but more specifically
the japanese variety of that five-act
structure called
johaku in the structure you start slowly
then gradually and smoothly accelerate
towards a very fast peak
now i find this particularly interesting
because this rhythm or flow can be seen
as quite different from the western idea
of beginning middle and end or acts one
two and three
since the latter tends to produce a
series of steps rather than a smooth
acceleration
in addition this concept of beginning
middle and end usually only refers to
the overall dramatic structure of a play
while joha cure
is used to support every moment of a
performance as well as its structure
each individual speech will have its own
internal johaku
every single gesture even employs its
own little micro joha cure
and that specific component to joha kyo
is what i find to be the most
interesting kick the japanese culture
even employs it in martial arts
which makes it the perfect fit for a
shonen story a story about
fighting in other words each and every
one of these five acts will also
experience their own internal joha cuis
with even the scenes inside it including
fight scenes adhering to this particular
structure
and in doing my research for this that
particular trait from this sort of story
structure i found to be the most
interesting
not only from a narrative standpoint but
from a sheer morbid curiosity one also
after looking and researching about joha
q i really wanted to see if oda applied
this sort of cohesion and commitment to
the johakur practice
and while act 1 did explore a large
number of reintroductions
new characters plot points and all the
rest of it it seems that while he was
building to these the format of joha q
was followed in smaller details and
scenes dotted throughout the first act
luffy shows up on the beach and explores
joe he gets into a minor conflict with
creatures
ha and finally he quickly dismantles the
bad guys beating a very fast and speedy
resolution
this sort of structure to the overall
flow of scenes and conversations can be
observed throughout the first act and
most definitely at its climax
which not only acts as its own internal
example of jo
ha and kyu but it also acts as an
example of a fast climax or representing
a cure
for the entire act as a whole and not
just that one scene i can't describe how
blown my mind was retroactively by
simply watching these old men describe
to me what joe hakio was
oda is doing the literary equivalent of
4d
chess right now and i'm actually a
little intimidated as a human being
i've never seen this level of commitment
to story structure and i'm sorry if i've
harped on about this for so long i just
needed to share this and to also justify
to myself the ungodly amount of time i
spent watching delightful men like this
guy describe to me what joe haku
actually is and to justify reading web
pages that looked like this
with that said after having read act 1
while i thought it was a phenomenal
outing for the series and one that has
in my opinion
set a strong standard for the rest of
the subsequent acts to uphold act 2
being the one that i'm discussing in
this video is
actually the one that i'm most excited
to look at as a case study at the
beginning of my last video i outlined
what i believe to be an issue with the
traditional modern three-act structure
that being its second act running the
risk of being rather vague or
at times uninteresting and this is where
i hope
joha kyo comes in otherwise i'll have
wasted 6 hours watching this guy
talk about 18th century japanese
scripture as i outlined in the prior
video i wanted to see if the japanese
technique could remedy
the issue that plagues the modern
three-act structure
so let's see let's dive into wano act 2
chapter 925 diving into this story the
first pattern i've become aware of has
been these small
single chapter intermissions discussing
the events of the outside world in some
small or
large way quickly before returning to
the action within the closed off
boundaries of wano country
right before act 1 began we got a
glimpse into cat viper's journey to
recruit marco from whitebeard's former
crew and it was pretty sad with marco
himself imparting a message that is
still unknown to us for to give to luffy
however
in this intermission we get something
way more interesting
through hawkeye reading the newspaper
like a disgruntled old man we learned
gekko moria is not only alive
but is marching an army of zombies on
blackbeard's crew but
that's not even the interesting part
apparently apsilon's clear clear fruit
ability has been taken from him and in
addition to that has been given to this
guy
remember him from impil down
well he's got it so yeah not great and
if that wasn't enough the
revolutionaries we saw getting ready for
a big mission during the reverie have
infiltrated sacred mary jo
to get kuma back and get this they are
currently clashing with fuji torah and
the other admiral ryokugyu
so it seems the world is on fire outside
of what's going on in the main plot
which
to be honest still doesn't have the best
sort of circumstances but what makes
this chapter particularly interesting
to me however is that whenever we do
peer outside of the events
of this one-o tale something even more
severe has happened
and what's more is that it reinforces
the idea that no
information is reaching luffy and the
gang while they're in
there adding to this feeling that
something massive is going to happen
while they are in wano and once they
finish their business there and connect
one with the rest of society they will
become aware of something even more
horrible or significant
that requires their immediate attention
thereafter which
would be once again a classic case of
the characters and events informing what
happens next in the narrative
their goal is to help free wano and in
doing so will cause them to become aware
of just
what transpired while they were in that
closed off box
it's a super interesting aspect of the
story that honestly makes me excited to
read the intermission between
each act all the more chapters 926 927
and 928 alrighty so now that we're
getting into the material for act 2
proper let's pay attention to two things
this is the first ha of johaku which
primarily dedicated to breaks or
development within the story and it
employs a slow start before quickly
building to something significant and a
climax that is self-contained in this
act
too with that said the curtain opens in
act 2 literally immediately setting
scenes for future events or
at least with some of them might think
that's the case there are instances
where otama is told that her ability is
very powerful which i mean it absolutely
is but i wonder how this power will come
into play
later in the story if at all within act
2 itself it definitely doesn't play a
super significant role therein i mean
she's already demonstrated that she
could become a master of creatures and
people far more powerful than her how
far can this trail of logic follow i
have no idea and how will it manifest
no clue there's some terrific meat in
this particular section too with
characters like shooting maru who've
demonstrated that they have ties to the
original kuzuki samurai guard
were given a nuanced jaded point of view
with this character resentful that for
20 years they were
forced to wait when they needed them and
throughout this act we explore what that
actually means with his character
as he introduces us to a large graveyard
which to this very day
haunts him and trust me added detail and
development is something we get a lot of
during this section too
in fact there was a theory i had brewing
with the character of kiku that turned
out to be
horribly incorrect that i plan on
sharing with you all a little later
however primarily the focus of these
chapters
centers around two different parts of
the story a prison break section which
is established with luffy and the second
the straw hat plan which which itself is
segmented between zoro who went missing
was sitting down with everyone this is
sort of like someone getting lost while
riding on a bus with you i mean these
are advanced levels of ineptitude when
it comes to staying together
i love zoro the rest of the straw hat
crew however are still together trying
to gain numbers for the revolution that
will be taking place
in a while and this is where the utility
of robin's position as a geisha i
mentioned in the first video
comes to be of great benefit she's
invited to a big feast
at the shogun's palace which is ideal
for gathering intel but is also when we
first learn of the existence of a
particular character called komuresaki
someone that's supposedly the most
beautiful woman
in wono
another minor aspect of this that i
liked was how these two characters
komorosaki and shogun
are built up both significant in very
different ways but i really like the
shogun specifically with it showing
interesting silhouettes depicting a
bunch of dragons or snakes
it's really cool and foreboding now i
realize that this is coming from someone
that literally just spent
eight hours researching 18th century
japanese approaches to literary
narrative and artistic endeavors and so
i acknowledge that there's no amount of
flowery language i can use to convince
you that i'm not the most boring person
alive today
but i found luffy's predicament a really
nice respite from the more complicated
aspects of the story for me
the bulk of the humor came from this
specific section it's honestly where
most of the interest came for me also
within this act and that's not to say
that the rest
isn't massively enjoyable it absolutely
is but i'm a big fan of these closed-off
small
scenes as they usually promote a lot of
creativity with this specifically
demonstrating cool new dynamics between
characters like luffy
and kid plowing through all of their
work while earning way more food than
should be physically possible but
perhaps the best new dynamic in this act
for me
comes between this little old man called
hugh that's struggling greatly and
luffy who helps him get the food he
needs and in some cases
the protection he requires i love this
not just because it's incredibly
endearing but also because it's setting
the foundation for something much more
significant down the line and it's all
to do with who luffy is as a person
and speaking of a person rize was a
person rizzo is there with luffy saying
that he's in the middle of spring luffy
out of this prison
this whole plot point right here it
connects with the rest of the main story
in a really significant and interesting
way that i honestly didn't see coming
but i will get to that later
the remaining section of these chapters
is then dedicated to the new characters
of komorowsaki and oliran that's said to
be
incredibly gorgeous and she is but what
makes this person as interesting as she
is
comes from her implied connection to
momonosuke his long-lost sister hiyori
and the fact that she's made a life out
of taking advantage of various people
on the funny side however there are
various scenes within this story where i
get
routinely confused as to whether i'm
looking at komorosaki
or robin without the anime's color
differences these two characters have
very little that set them apart in an
obvious way checkers 929
930 and 931 these chapters open up with
a character called minatomo
and my one piece secret service pointed
out something hilarious to me
alright check it out so remember back in
chapter one
no me neither well back in chapter one
this guy called higumi the bear
barges his way into the bar and in doing
so breaks the door
however when he leaves as you can see
there's a continuity error when he
leaves the building the door is back in
place so
i could hear you all saying okay it's a
continuity error from almost a thousand
chapters ago
so what mark stop wasting my time first
of all back up
quit harsh in my chill but also you see
at the beginning of every chapter oda
likes to do a little question corner
wherein he takes and answers questions
from fans
one such question asks about this
particular inconsistency in chapter one
oda's response i quote oh that's just mr
minitomo
the carpenter's doing he even included a
quick little illustration on the side
now this was obviously a throwaway joke
but does that little doodle look
familiar to you
because it should it's the same design
and same family name
of the carpenter pictured in this
chapter i love stuff like this and it
goes to show
what sort of crazy memory oda has
whether it be for pivotal plot points or
crazy silly pointless stuff like this
contrasting that however with something
a little more serious
as i pointed out in the prior chapters
it was teased who the shogun of wano was
and what he looked like and once again
we get some exchange between he
and an individual he executes and this
individual isn't just
anyone he shoots a member of cp 0.
that's right he doesn't care that they
represent the celestial dragon's
interest or that they have the backing
of the entire navy
and that's because his confidence comes
from kaido
backing him up he fears no celestial
dragon or naval force
he is an island into and of himself and
following this
he's finally revealed shogun orochi
surrounded by wealth
women and all the food he can eat and
the page spread that this man is
revealed on is a great sequence of
panels demonstrating where he is
and zooms out to the wastelands of his
own creation
and the factories that make the land so
now honestly
i really enjoy this guy as a character
his design and overall presence reminds
me of king wapple only better
in every conceivable way in my opinion
this is king rappel done well
he's threatening because of his
allegiances and to top it all off has
some pretty dope powers that i will be
discussing in a moment
right so at this point i probably should
point out this arc dedicates a lot of
time to two
characters specifically zoro whom we all
should be very familiar with at this
point if you're not i don't know how you
found this video and the second person
this self-proclaimed sycophant called
yazoo he leads zord to the village of
ibizu and to be perfectly honest i
didn't really think too much about this
town or this person
or what sort of relevance it will have
for the story it's a poverty-stricken
town much like the rest of wano with the
only difference being everyone is
smiling and rejoicing all the time
regardless of their situation for now
zoro takes it as a philosophical outlook
all these people share
but as the story progresses the dark
truth behind this village is nothing
short of horrific
okay you're still there okay
good because this is when the story
starts to ramp up in a big way and
speaking of big
bomb is here and she is mad immediately
she tries to scale the falls of wano
with the giant coy on her ship
however naturally kaido wants her to
stay far away from his territory and
thus deploys one of his henchmen to sort
of the situation
which they do quite effectively the
curious thing about this particular
exchange however is that had katakuri
been present on the ship they might have
been able to avoid or block the attack
altogether using his future site
abilities
and perhaps might have even succeeded in
skating the falls which is
on its own a really cool detail but also
a fantastic piece of continuity
following on from whole cake island
regardless big mom falls into the ocean
with not even her crew
knowing where she went as a devil fruit
wielder this is
extremely dangerous and practical death
sentence and
to be perfectly honest a lot of stuff
happens in this act like i'm looking
over my notes right now and there's an
absurd amount of detail to cover
like i didn't even get a chance to touch
on the little scrap the straw hats get
into while they defend this little
smiling girl called otoko
all the while they're looking to recruit
more people for the rebellion like i
mean
they need like 5 000 and they are
nowhere near that number right now but
the cool part is that within this scrap
sanji finally uses his garma suit that
his family gave to him and it's pretty
sick
allowing him to go unseen pretty much
anywhere he wants to while also
heightening
all of his abilities i'm just gonna
pretend the whole spying on his fellow
crewmates in a bathhouse
didn't happen you know because why tyron
is such an amazing power open character
with yet another crude and self-serving
gag
oh and as i mentioned earlier robin's at
the party looking for poneglyphs and
get this big mom washes up on the beach
right near chopper kiku momo and otama
but
and this is the weird part she has
amnesia
what jokes aside though i'm not sure how
i feel about this
i mean i accept that in order for a
story to work there's a certain amount
of suspension of disbelief that goes
into it from the audience but
within reason i was willing to accept
that an act one luffy washed up on the
beach alone and i'm also willing to
accept that big mom did the same maybe
there's a specific current or something
i don't know who's to say but for big
mom now to also have
amnesia when she hasn't had a history of
that before in the series and it just so
happens to be the only situation that
could allow her
to travel with the straw hats it feels
less like carefully planned writing and
more like oda trying to fit a triangle
peg into a circular hole at least to me
so much so that for the entire time she
was with chopper in them i had this
feeling in the back of my head that she
was faking it somehow in order to keep a
low profile while she was separated from
her crew but
as it happens it's real now with that
said as a narrative tool she acts as a
terrific means with which to garner
tension for the story she's effectively
a ticking time bomb no one knows when
she'll suddenly recall who the straw
hats are and when she does
it's gonna be a big deal checkers
932-937 within these chapters there are
three significant plot points that
really caught my attention
and that i thoroughly enjoyed the first
being that of the feast held by shogun
orochi
wherein robin is discovered by some
henchmen and by some henchmen i mean a
whole lot of henchmen but she uses her
clone ability to escape which always
seems to catch
me off guard because of this eventually
nami is forced to intervene and help but
by far the most interesting part happens
when the little girl otoko gets on the
nerves of arochi and komorosaki
is forced to stand up for her she even
slaps him first off
awesome second awesome and thirdly
the character komorosaki really keeps me
on my toes
in one scene she's cunning men out of
their life savings and in another she's
defending a little girl
with seemingly zero fear demonstrated
super effectively on this page spread
showcasing the powers of orochi in all
of its terrifying glory he's
intimidating but kumarasaki refuses to
yield to his whims which is
freaking cool right after this act of
defiance however kyoshiro slashes down
kobarosaki and this is when nami makes
the last minute clutch play to save the
game
drops down and unloads the full brunt of
zeus onto the palace it's a brilliant
panel with a terrific sense of scale and
power
and really this entire arc so far has
been one negative thing happening after
the next
all the plans seem to be falling apart
or meeting dead ends
even regarding the situation with luffy
and hyo back at the prison the situation
worsens
particularly after kyo begins getting
punished by the wardens yet again
and in typical luffy fashion he well
you know the rest once again these are
my favorite scenes in the act because
they're so wholesome
luffy shares his food tickets with the
old man who's starving
the old guy gets into trouble for having
them in the first place and then luffy
defends him it's a really simple story
but then
something super interesting comes to our
attention about this old guy apparently
he had tremendous influence over the
people living in wano years back
and the folks suck inside this prison
well they were put there for crimes
against the current shogun which means
all the numbers we need for the
rebellion are technically
right here in the prison they don't know
it yet but they've put the straw hat
captain in the exact place he needs to
be to make this plan
work i mean not that luffy knows
anything about this yet but it's a good
step forward
as i've said before the trend of this
tale is of worsening circumstances and
situations
and just when you thought luffy couldn't
be in a worse predicament
they'd take off his cuffs and replace
them with a celestial dragon
collar a car that was sliced off his
head if he or he'll leaves or gets
knocked out of the sumo ring
[Music]
ooh tension naturally luffy isn't fazed
by this and so instead of seeing this as
the dire set of circumstances that it is
he instead views it as an opportunity to
get stronger he knows he can't defeat
kylo yet so
why not train i guess and now finally we
get to a clear highlight of this act
and what i am sure many of you have been
waiting for that being the encounter
zoro has in the snow with an individual
trying to take his weapons
first off this section starts out with a
really neat call back to thriller park
where zoro dukes it out with a legend of
one oh in a character called
ryuma they clash for a while over the
sword in question but that's when we get
a major convergence of two separate plot
lines
zorro and the fleeing komorosaki and
otoko bleeding
i absolutely love this section not
really because i noticed anything
particularly incredible about it
narratively but because i just
love zoro as a character and he hasn't
really had his own chance to shine in
this story yet
or at least not for quite some time too
often i think he's relegated to dealing
with something that luffy doesn't have
time to deal with and he is fantastic in
that role don't get me wrong
but i love getting the chance to see him
in his own little subplot that has now
intertwined with the komorosaki
plot which i have lots to talk about by
the way to make matters worse however
another character makes himself known
a criminal from the flower capital
called hitokiri kamaza who
let me tell you apart from being hella
strong has a much more significant role
to play in this tale beyond what he's
shown to be
right now my personal highlight within
this fight has to be the ebb and flow of
zoro's attention having to direct from
one tough threat to the next
all the while trying to defend a woman
and child this act really helps me
connect with and appreciate zorro
all the more but as the fight presses on
it's looking to be that little bit too
much for him
[Music]
this was awesome in the most zoro way i
can think of i mean we're talking about
the kind of guy who was willing to cut
off his legs to free himself in little
garden and for him to use this reckless
side of his personality to gain the
upper hand on this individual
is a brilliant choice i think and that's
not even to make mention of the anime's
version of this scene that elevates the
entire altercation to the next level
with superb
and dynamic animation but with zoro now
gravely wounded and with the battle
looming in the coming days
and now only having two swords things
really aren't looking good for the one
eye swordsman especially now that the
forces of orochi have been catching on
to the rebellion's plans and the secret
messages
everything is going wrong
[Music]
i want to thank surfsharkvpn for
sponsoring today's video in the ocean of
online content there's a lot of websites
that take your info without you even
knowing it but you can swim under their
radar using surfsharkvpn with this
particular service you can stop websites
from tracking your info and selling
targeted ads to you online
completely protecting your privacy
nothing is creepier than when you have a
conversation with a friend about
something and it pops up in your ads
plus with surfshark hard luck id
protection you'll even get an alert when
some rando jerk is trying to break into
your email
but one of my personal favorite features
of surf shark is that you can see
content that's not available in your
area for instance did you know that
right now on netflix you can have the
first 130 episodes of one piece
well if you live in a country where
that's not available you can just log in
with surf surfshark and you can get
access to that or any other show or film
that that isn't normally available for
you
so if you want both freedom and
protection online click the link in the
description and use code tnm
it not only gives you a whopping 83 off
the regular price
but also three months of service totally
for free
surf shark also offers a 30-day
money-back guarantee so there's no risk
to even try it out for yourself so if
this service sounds interesting to you
or you want to support the channel
please check it out now back to the
video none of you pirates on this ship
have the proper appreciation for booty
[Music]
chapters 938 to 945.
i had this theory i was writing where i
was convinced lady toki hiyori and
momonosuke's mother was
in fact kiku because of how she spoke
and how different she was to all of the
others in comparison i figured that
since yori was thought dead too
but turned out to be alive that lady
taki would be alive also but
back to komorosaki claiming to be momo's
sister she says
she wasn't allowed to go into the future
with them because and i quote
if something happened to one of us the
kozuki blood might still live on now
i'm not sure i believe that to be a good
excuse i mean
they're in a burning building full of
enemies something tells me one route is
less dangerous or treacherous than the
other but then again she did have an
escape route with kawamatsu saving her
that also helped protect and raise her
up until
she was 13 years of age he was
apparently a powerful samurai
and this is the individual locked up in
the cell that's never to be opened in
the same place where luffy is right now
apparently there are also nine samurai
that are significant which is great
seeing as so many of them seem to be
coming out of the woodwork and making
themselves known but in saying that the
rebellion needs to be reworked because
as of right now the villages and capital
are crawling with folks
rounding up those with the tattoo of the
crescent moon which shows support for
the rebellion
and that's when this dude moses on into
town this fellow is the very same
gentleman that guided
zoro to ibizu and alongside the rest of
the straw hats who don't know him also
he ruminates over what it might take to
take the attention away from them once
more to gain the advantage
overall they don't really come up with
anything but they do learn more about
this
fellow how he gives everything he has to
those of the village and how he is in
fact
otoko's father he works tirelessly for
the benefit of his village and to look
after his daughter it's a wonderful
example of how other likes to take
certain characters that feel like
comedic side notes to the main event and
recontextualizes that there's a tragic
struggle behind the unrelenting smile
and
in more ways than one as we soon will
find out back over in udon there's this
phenomenal scene luffy's taking on the
various guards in the area and
now obviously the drawback with this
situation is less to do with luffy being
able to hold his own but
more so yo struggling he's admission to
not wanting to hold luffy back and
that's when luffy uses his observation
haki to guide hyo
away from the enemy's attacks by seeing
into the future
it's a really unusual but awesome way to
incorporate teamwork in the fight but
what's more is noticing the power and
hearing luffy refer to it as hockey pure
realizes that it must be the very same
invisible power
found in wano later revealed as ryo and
vows to help teach luffy that power but
which he seeks the ability to damage
enemies
without touching them this is so
wonderful for a number of reasons
firstly it adds a little bit of flavor
to wano in the same way that they have
their own currency but it also helps
build upon
this notion that guano is very much an
isolated nation from the rest of the
world
but most critically and well it's almost
the most exciting thing
luffy now has an active mentor which if
his last fight with kaido was anything
to go by
he is in dire need of having what
follows is luffy making easy work of the
guards as he tries his best to master
his advanced hockey this is a
really interesting new format for
gaining abilities in one piece in the
past a lot of luffy's power-ups are
off-screen and explained later down the
line oda has typically avoided the
battle shown in trainiacs that make up
many other series like dragon ball there
are exceptions of course particularly
around the time skip but the battle with
katakuri really brought this idea of
luffy learning through battle and by
adapting to a situation to the forefront
of the narrative and it continues right
here
he was literally writing luffy while he
beats up enemies like some sort of
mutant yoshi it's amazing
and easily the lighthearted highlight of
the act for me that is
until the bobble-headed ninja ryzer
rolls up masterfully cloaked under
caribou oh oh yeah that one from the
sabbati arc with the horrifying nickname
wet-haired caribou that conjures up the
most horrific visions of
yeah he's back and he supposedly changed
his ways
pulling the weirdest face in the process
of revealing this and that of course
works on luffy because
luffy's luffy what makes this scene so
impactful however is that it enlightens
hyo
to the truth that the akazaya samurai
and momonosuke
are alive the rebellion is still alive
this is supremely important as he goes
on to reveal that almost all the
prisoners here in udon are imprisoned
entirely because
they oppose orochi and if he were to
reveal this to everyone he'd effectively
have an
army at his disposal despite hearing of
hyo's past
we finally see the spark with him
reignite a hope washes
over udon that is until
it seems we can't have too much
happiness in mono apparently
in spite of the optimistic news in udon
back in the capital orochi has
apprehended elusive ushimitsu kozo and
plans to execute him alongside
komorowsaki's funeral unfortunately as
brooke encounters zoro yori and toko
it's revealed that kozo is none other
than
honoyasu our poor smiley do-gooder
fearing for his father's life toku
rushes back to the capital at blistering
speed with the others in pursuit it's a
rudimentary tool but it's a smart way of
getting everyone pointed towards the
same location
focusing the plot while introducing a
layer of personal tension
will she make it in time adding to this
the execution is being broadcast across
the land and the gang who recently
learned of yasu's history in episode
look on in horror as if this wasn't
shocking enough as kanjuro and shinobu
lay eyes upon the scene the significance
of the event becomes clear
tonoyasu is in fact yasu the hedgehog
the daimyo of hakumai and comrade
of the infamous odin the stakes could
not
possibly be higher right now and all of
the solutions are either too far away
stuck
simply watching or both the situation
is quite literally helpless and yasu
knows this
but he's prepared for it and he delivers
one of the most impactful speeches in
the ark
thus far in a land where its inhabitants
are so oppressed so
terrified of their rulers yasu is
unwavering in spite of his dire
situation
he not only mocks his current
circumstances by admitting he's not
actually
kozo but he also addresses orochi
outright and condemns the way he ravaged
such a wonderful country in one without
batting an eye he calls him nothing more
than vermin in one is the most
emotionally and heroic lie yet in the
series he takes responsibility for the
symbol of the uprising
claiming it to be nothing but a prank
this is absolutely
genius for two reasons firstly it
protects the rebellion and gives them a
tactical advantage once again
but secondly it humiliates orochi beyond
comprehension destroying his reputation
in the process
as orochi prepares to deliver the final
blow yasu throws out one last bout of
humiliation reciting words that cut deep
into orochi's heart
a man of such small caliber shall never
in his life
truly devour odin orochi's crosshairs
plant themselves firmly on yasu as he
rallies the nation towards onigishima as
a flurry of bullets pierce yasuo toko
finally arrives on the scene desperately
calling out to her father and what
follows this is one of the most shocking
moments in all of one
this is one of the most horrifically
twisted moments
in all of one piece and it is executed
to perfection on just about
every level structurally this
corresponds to the hot part of the
kabuki play structure
where events begin to escalate at a
rapid pace yasu's words are for all
intents and purposes the match
that ignites the fuse of battle and the
next reveal only adds fuel to that fire
overwhelmed by grief hiori and shinobu
unveiled the secret of ibizu town the
smiles they wear are nothing but masks
horrific contortions caused by the aptly
named smile fruits with only a 10
success rate the failures wipe out the
consumer's ability to express sorrow
or anger leaving only laughter in yet
another tragic twist
it's revealed orochi shipped the
defective fruits to the starving ibusu
town residence for no other reason but
psychotic satisfaction now obviously
cruelty is nothing new for one piece but
this
takes the cake for arguably the most
disturbing revelation of the series so
far
the idea of never being able to express
grief is horrifying the idea of being
trapped behind a false smile
of course resonates with so many people
it's akin to the joker's laughing gas in
the batman franchise it's nothing but
unrelenting psychopathy orochi is
perhaps the most vindictive character in
all of one piece
what an absolute monster so far i've
held myself together fairly well but
otoko
broke me took my heart and crushed it as
she lays over her fallen father
fighting back tears and laughter she
begs him to come back to life pulling
out medicine
toed oil she says promising it will cure
him oda
you sick and twisted master of tragedy
to have planted what seemed like a
throwaway gag for usof at the start of
this arc only to bring it back around as
a vessel to torture your reader and
even torture usop a character who had to
watch his own mother pass away from
illness
it's on another level of total and utter
cruel genius
i normally read through these chapters
in bulk writing my notes as i go but
when i came to this scene
this small exchange i fell apart and
needless to say had to step away for a
few minutes
but thankfully upon my return oda was
right there for me with comforting arms
as orochi takes notice of otoko he fires
at her and in what is one of the coolest
reunions to date
it's zorro and sanji to the rescue for
the first time since dressrose said the
boys are back together and holy crap
is it awesome needless to say i sort of
well
maybe okay almost definitely squealed
with excitement over that moment what
follows this is a chaotic impromptu
scramble by
all the straw hats present trying to
save toko and to retrieve her now
deceased father in order to give him the
proper burial that he deserves there's
some great action here with usopp
getting stuck in with his slingshot and
even zorro using
everything in his power right now to
take out the cruel tyrant inurochi
however his two sword attack gets
blocked by kyoshiro this character is
creepy as all hell and is ridiculously
dedicated to orochi's protection
thankfully however they managed to
escape but just as things are wrapping
up here
luffy is dealing with his own situation
someone is knocking on the door
of the udon prison camp
[Music]
so this is the wild card element i was
talking about regarding big mom in this
story as mentioned before luffy can't
leave this circle without his collar
yeeting his head right off
and now big mom is demolishing the area
but diamonds are made under extreme
pressure
and it doesn't get any more pressurized
than this
as luffy and hill are sent flying from
the arena floor and outside of the
perimeter
luffy suddenly becomes infused with
outward hockey
obviously this is super cool but it also
begs the question from me we've now
seen advanced forms of armament hockey
and observation haki
so i wonder what advanced supreme king
haki
looks like and with very few people even
possessing the power itself
finding a master might be harder than
you might think however
as demonstrated with hyo and katakuri
luffy can learn under extreme pressure
and while facing an adversary
so my prediction this advanced supreme
king haki will be taught to him by
red-haired shanks when he ultimately has
to face off against him
now if you thought this scene was over
you're sorely mistaken as it happens the
warden managed to inadvertently restore
big mom's memory by
bonking her super hard in the head and
once he has her down he
chains her up to the gills in c prism
stone it's honestly hilarious the
precautions these folks are taking in
apprehending an emperor of the sea these
emperors
really are a force of nature in the
ensuing chaos caused by big mom
kawamatsu is freed from his cell just in
time to see rounds of plague
fired onto the prison population to
contain the riots the imagery
is honestly pretty horrific this
population of people in this prison
largely are there
simply because they disagree with the
psychotic direction this tyrannical
shogun has forced their once great
country to go down one that
as it happens has led kids crewmate to
suffer the same
fate as those from ibizu village on top
of this also working as a great swerve
associating this killer with the same
person that ambushed zoro in the snow
it also explains why kid hates kaido so
much
and what he vowed to be the one to take
him out when he was face to face with
luffy earlier
however nothing can be done if everyone
is resigned to dying from this plague
and that's when luffy steps in luffy is
a bonafide and in the truest sense of
the term a natural
born leader he does not see himself as
more or less worthy than anybody and
standing in direct contrast with shogun
orochi
decides to lead by example inflicting
himself with the plague to rile up the
prisoners and to lift their spirits
i love this speech for so many reasons
but more than anything
it once again granted oda the
opportunity to demonstrate exactly what
it is about luffy that
we love and respect as a character this
scene also boasts the most
badass luffy line in the series check it
out luffy stops this elephant man's
trunk from firing another one of these
rounds
and before it goes off he ties it into
the trunk and calmly states
i saw a pretty bad future just now
that's just
cold-blooded awesome and intimidating as
all hell right there
thankfully though chopper and the rest
of those traveling with big mom at the
time
are there too to provide backup for
luffy who's losing his strength fast
however quite auspiciously momo is seen
by everyone in the facility bringing
forth new vigor onto the ranks of the
prison they have now
something to fight for the rest of the
subsequent arc is comprised of various
events that count down the days until
the rebellion in them we get some
outstandingly entertaining scenes like
the tense conversations between big mom
and kaido wherein
they form an alliance with some truly
crazy imagery like these shadowy giant
creatures referred to simply as
numbers i'm not sure who or what they
are but i know that they are there for
the fire festival
whatever that means there's also some
truly interesting scenes between law and
hawkins who find himself at the wrong
end of law's sword hawkins reveals why
he no longer has an alliance with kids
citing that joining kaido was his only
option i see this as law looking into
the mirror
something law seems to be having trouble
with in this arc itself specifically is
coming to terms with the fact
luffy and kaido are going to fight and
he needs to choose which side he's going
to be on the straw hats and he have
already clashed calling his crew's
abilities into question
and that's not even to make mention of
how stressed out he gets around
luffy right now law strikes me as a sort
of wild card though i doubt very much
he'll betray luffy when all the cards
are down
but you never know at the very end of
chapter 955 the worst happens
orochi receives leaked and updated
information regarding the rebellion and
where it's going to be starting it's
insinuated through paneling that law was
the one who leaked that to the shogun
but that seems misleading to me it's
too obvious in my mind i think two
people are the two most likely trainers
amidst this group
kiku and komorosaki komorosaki for
reasons i stated prior her introductory
scenes demonstrated a much more
unkind woman that would do anything to
get what she wanted with that said
though
while momo wouldn't recognize her she
has demonstrated knowledge of her own
family's sword
and the fact that kawamatsu vouches for
her then again she hasn't seen him in
about
13 years and a lot of changes could have
come about in that time but
yeah i'm not too sure on her personally
or even kiku for that matter
the only aspect that makes me worry of
her is that zoro had his suspicions
about her and he usually is a great
judge of character these are both
probably wildly incorrect but this is
what my god is telling me right now much
of the prelude to this ending focuses on
the successful recruitment of various
rebel forces to bolster their ranks as
well as training for luffy and ironing
out the plan of attack
we get some nice backstories on the
individuals that took zoro's sword and
the location of a hideout that contains
the weaponry that will be used during
this revolution this weaponry was
guarded by this
fox spirit and the imagery of this fox
is honestly gorgeous and matches
japanese symbolism of foxes perfectly
in japan they are seen as guardians to
many shrines across the country but
perhaps most importantly zoro comes to
obtain
a new sword and not just any sort this
is the sword owned by odin himself and
is given to him by hiyori
zorro attempts to use the sword and in
doing so almost loses his entire arm
this is a ludicrously powerful sword and
one zorro is keen to master because
for kaido the only wound he's ever
received has been from this blade
and thus closes the curtain on act two
what a phenomenal development of all the
events established in the first act
there was plenty of action but the
sorrow of some of these events during
this act
has to be up there as some of the most
harrowing in the series
next week will be my final series review
for one piece until act three concludes
and after that i'll be tackling a bunch
of the movies across various videos
also i plan on commencing a brand new
review series pretty soon i've asked on
twitter and nepal on youtube which ones
you guys think i should tackle
and you all seem to be split down the
middle on hunter hunter and jojo's
bizarre adventure so let me know what
your suggestions are in the comment
section down below maybe you'll
influence the next series i also need to
review the morrow arc of dragon ball
super pretty soon too so look forward to
that however for those of you that want
to see the missing one piece episodes
that toei have taken down from youtube
they are available on my patreon
these include the marine ford dressrosa
and part one reviews
but that'll do it for this video as
always i've been told not mark i'll see
you all next week and thank you all so
much for sharing this year with me
and your amazing support on patreon it
genuinely means the world
you